Guten Tag.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz, als Sintetin und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespiele führen.
Sind Sie damit ein Farbster?
Ja natürlich, Hauptsache, jemand guckt nach mir.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Petra Franke.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Frau Frank, ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
Sie sind Frau, ich bin 42.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Wie viel wiegeln Sie so seit?
80 kg.
Frau Frank, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich habe solche heftigen Bauchschmerzen.
Es ging heute Nacht.
Gestern Abend spät an, heute Nacht.
Ich habe mich die ganze Nacht gequält.
Heute Morgen musste ich mich auch einmal übergeben.
Wir hatten gestern Abend ein bisschen fettiges Essen.
Danach hatte ich solche Bauchschmerzen.
Es ging im oberen Bauchbereich.
Es wurde immer heftig.
Es hat ganz stark gedrückt.
Es hat bis in den Rücken reingestrahlt.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, die Schmerzen gehen so rundherum.
Um den ganzen Bauch.
Mir war so schlecht.
Frau Frank, wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Sie haben uns schon gesagt, Oberbau.
Im rechten oder linken Seite?
Oder in der Mitte?
Ja, die Schmerzen gehen rundherum.
Sie haben heftige Schmerzen.
Können Sie genauer beschreiben?
Sind Sie ehrstähnend oder biregend?
Nein, heftiger Druck.
Ja.
Sie sagt in rück.
Das strahlt so ein bisschen in den Rücken rein.
Rücken.
In den Schaum oder in den unteren Rücken.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Das ist nicht krampfartig.
Sind die Schmerzen nach dem Ästen aufgetreten?
Ja, genau.
Umfassend.
Aber nach einer halben, dreiviertel Stunde ging das mit einem los.
Oh, dann war mir das so schlecht.
Sie haben seit gestern Nacht Bauchschmerzen?
Ja.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Nein, das ging wie eingeschaltet.
Ganz plötzlich.
Okay.
Sie mussten sich übergeben.
Wie sah das Erbruch hinaus?
Das waren ein bisschen Reste von dem Essen.
Ein bisschen gelblicher, bitterer Schleim.
Ja, sicher.
Okay.
Ist die noch einen Momentanübel?
Ja, doch.
Schlecht ist mir noch.
Die Schmerzen sind eben auch immer noch da.
Deswegen bin ich ja auch gekommen zu ihnen.
Wie ist der Appetit?
Hören Sie bloß auf.
Ich mag überhaupt nichts essen.
Ich kann gar nicht mal an Essen denken.
Wie häufig oder wie viel haben Sie sich übergeben?
Nur einmal.
Das war eigentlich nur einmal, ja.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich fieberig, Frau Franke?
Ich fieberig nehme so eigentlich nicht.
Mir ist nur grauenvoll schlecht und eben diese Bauchschmerzen.
Sie haben keine.
Haben Sie Schütz und Frust oder Nachtschweiß?
Ja, ich habe mich geschwitzt.
Ich habe mir mit Zwischenbrüchen einmal einen frischen Schlafanzug anziehen.
Weil ich so geschwitzt habe.
Warte, das ist ein bisschen schmerz.
Ich wechsle jetzt noch ein bisschen.
Nein, eigentlich noch nicht.
Okay.
Ich habe noch ein bisschen Schmerz.
Das ist so viel.
Ja, so Blähungen habe ich eigentlich ziemlich oft, ja.
Und das hatte ich jetzt die Tage, also heute Nacht und heute Morgen auch.
Okay.
Habt ihr probleme?
Barmasalasnoda, mitam Schuturgang, ist alles in Ordnung?
Normalerweise ist alles in Ordnung.
Aber jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, das ist gar nichts in Ordnung.
Z.B. von Walböse Schuturgang.
Ja, ich denke mal gestern Mittag so etwas war das ja.
Gestern.
Haben Sie etwas ungewöhnliches Beemars beim Schuturgang oder?
Ja, das war alles ganz normal.
Das ganze Theater ging erst los nach diesem Essen.
Z.B. Haben Sie Berenen Barmasalasnoda?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Alles in Ordnung, okay.
Haben Sie Sotberenen oder Sauerstoßen, Frau Franke?
Normalerweise eigentlich nicht.
Aber heute würde ich sagen, ja, das ist alles ziemlich hoch.
Ja, da würde ich das schon eher bejahen, ja.
Ziemlich hoch.
Okay, sehr gut.
Momentan.
Okay.
Ja, haben Sie auch Brustschmerzen, Frau Franke?
Was für Schmerzen?
Brust, Brust, oder Engelgefür, Brustschmerzen.
Nein, Brustschmerzen habe ich nicht.
Ja, genau.
Ne, ne, nur der Paar auch so, ne?
Super.
Okay, ne, Herr Franke?
Frau Franke, ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich das nicht habe.
Frau Franke, haben Sie ungewollte Indianisten,
seid ab oder zu genoven?
Also, ich wieg mich jetzt nicht ständig,
aber das schrankt natürlich mal um ein Kilo hin oder her.
Aber können wir sagen, es ist natürlich nicht so stabil.
Wie schlafen Sie Frau Franke?
Normalerweise schlafe ich gut,
aber letzte Nacht habe ich natürlich ganz schlecht geschlafen.
Okay.
Frau Franke, leiden Sie auch Krönischen,
kranken Sie ja, ich meine mit Blut,
so eine Krankheit, Bluthochdruck, oder
ansteckende Krankheiten?
Also, ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, ja.
Seit wann?
Hat man so vor vier Jahren mal festgestellt
und ich habe auch ein bisschen erhöhte
so Cholesterinwerte, aber bisher habe ich dem nicht so viel
Bedeutung beigemessen.
Und ich nehme da zwar gegen den Blutdruck,
gegen den hohen, nehme ich Tabletten,
aber ich weiß nicht, wie die heißen.
Und dann habe ich noch einen Medikament,
das nehme ich, aber nur, wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe,
ich habe so Migräneattacken.
Und dann muss ich immer gleich etwas nehmen,
um das praktisch abzustellen.
Und ich könnte Ihnen aber jetzt gerade nicht sagen,
wie das heißt.
Die Sachen habe ich alle zu Hause liegen,
aber ich weiß nicht, wie die Medikamente sind.
Sehr haupt und ihre Medikamente nicht wissen,
oder nicht erinnert.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die heißen.
Ich kann Ihnen nur sagen, ich nehme da jeden Morgen
gegen den Blutdruck.
Und wie gesagt, bei Migräne habe ich da auch meine Tabletten liegen.
Und dann kann ich die einen nehmen.
Ja, okay.
Frau Franke, haben Sie auch für Ihre Akronenbeschwarten
etwas probiert?
Ich habe mich eigentlich nicht getraut,
irgendwas zu nehmen, weil mir so furchtbar schlecht war
und weil es auch alles so schnell gegangen ist.
Und ich habe natürlich versucht, mir eine Wärmsflasche
auf den Bauch zu legen.
Aber irgendwie, das war alles Quatsch, das hat alles nicht geholfen.
Ich gehe auf ihn.
Okay.
Frau Franke, wie ist es mit der Schmerz?
Auf einer Schmerzspiehle von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leichte und 10 starke Schmerzen sind.
Also die sind schon sehr heftig.
Ich würde sagen, vielleicht bei 8, ja.
8, ja, sehr halbunrecht.
Normalerweise, Frau Franke, ich werde Sie untersuchen,
aber können Sie bis zum Ende des Geschiebreichs
diese Schmerzen aushalten oder
ich renne damit ja schon den ganzen Abend jetzt ja rum, ja.
Okay.
Frau Franke, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ja, als Kind, also da habe ich mal den Blinter rausbekommen.
Okay.
Gibt es sonstige Operationen?
Nee, sonst ist alles ohne Operation bisher gelaufen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Alargen oder Unfallträglichkeiten?
Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich gegen irgendwas allerges bin.
Und ich konnte bisher auch alles essen, was ich wollte.
Also wüsste jetzt nicht, dass irgendwas nicht bekömmlich ist.
Frau Franke, rauchen Sie?
Ja, leider.
Wie viele Seguriten rauchen Sie täglich?
Ja, ungefähr ein Päckchen am Tag.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Oh, schon 20 Jahre.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Also nicht viel.
Also ich trink so zwei Flaschen Bier am Abend
und naja, wenn wir mal was feiern oder so,
dann trinke ich natürlich auch ein bisschen mehr
und da gibt es dann auch mal,
was ich in Schnaps oder ein Cocktail
oder so ein bisschen was mit mehr Prozenten oder so.
Aber so regelmäßig eigentlich so zwei Flaschen Bier abends.
Ja, regelmäßig.
Okay.
Trinken Sie auf Schnaps, auf jeden Tag?
Nein, nein, das nur, wenn es irgendwelche Feste gibt
oder also ja, so, was was ich,
wenn jemand Geburtstag feiert
oder ja, nach einem guten Essen oder so,
dann trinkt man schon mal ein Schnaps mehr.
Okay.
Frau Frank, gibt es in Ihrer Familie
chronischer Frankenjagd,
Leben Ihrer Tamro?
Meine Eltern, die leben noch, aber ja, also ich weiß,
die haben beide auch ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck
und meine Mutter, die hat auch mal was von
von Colin, ansonsten sind hier eigentlich gesund.
Brauchen Sie auch Geschwister?
Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder, ja, und der ist auch wirklich krank.
Der, der hat eine Leberzirose, also
dem geht es gar nicht gut.
Und der hat so einen ganz aufgeblähten Bauch,
das ist alles voll Wasser, also das ist ganz schrecklich, ja.
Ja, ich verstehe, das ist sehr schwierig für Sie.
Wie alt, ja?
Oh, mein Bruder, der ist 30.
Was machen Sie, Beroflich, Frau Franka?
Ich arbeite als Laborantin in einer Farbenfabrik.
Ja, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ja, wir haben zwei Kinder.
Die sind aber, also, ja, die sind aus dem Gröbchen,
sind hier raus, aber die sind auch bei uns zu Hause, ja.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, Gott sei Dank sind sie gesund, ja.
Ja, super.
Haben Sie Schittres bei der Arbeit oder im Leben?
Stress, bisschen Stress hat jeder, aber ich würde jetzt nicht sagen,
nicht übermäßig viel.
Nicht übermäßig, okay.
Frau Franka, warten Sie in der nächsten Zeit im Ausland?
War ich im Ausland?
Ja, wir waren einmal in den Weihnachtsferien,
waren wir in Dänemark, ja, aber also nix exotisches.
Okay.
Haben Sie alle erholenen Impfungen bekommen, Frau Franka?
Sie meinen jetzt die Covid-Impfung oder was?
Ja, Covid oder gegen Hepatitis oder...
Ja, so was ich hatte ist eine Tetanus-Impfung.
Und ansonsten, ja, so, ich glaube, so ziemlich aktuell ist das mit den Impfungen schon.
Meine Hausarzt fragt immer, ob ich alles habe, ja.
Trägt es regelmäßig Sport?
Also, als Sportlich würde ich das nicht bezeichnen.
Ich fahre halt jeden Tag mit dem Fahrrad zur Arbeit
und zum Einkaufen fahre ich viel mit dem Fahrrad,
aber also jetzt nicht sportlich, nicht, dass ich da jede Stunde auf dem Rennrad rumfahre.
Okay.
Frau Franka, ich bin schon fertig.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie noch andere Wäsche?
Ja, das ist lang eine völlig, was ich da so habe.
Ich möchte jetzt halt nur wissen, was man dagegen tun kann
und woher das überhaupt kommt, ja.
Ja, so war es, Frau Franka, natürlich, war ich, war ich sich körperlich hinzufügen.
Insbesondere, ja, da hatte ich ihr Ball.
Dann natürlich war ich Blutabnehmen.
Sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen,
war ich sie über die Behandlung, die Ergebnisse informieren.
Okay.
Okay, das klingt gut.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Angeblich, früher angeblich werden.
Ah, ja, genau.
Also vor einer knappen Woche hatte ich einmal auch nach dem Essen so ein bisschen beschwerden,
aber längst nicht so heftig wie jetzt.
Und das hat sich dann auch eigentlich wieder zurückgebildet.
Deswegen habe ich dem keine Beachtung geschenkt.
Und meine zweite Frage ist, sind Sie regelmäßig Genecologie untersucht?
Mein Genecologen, zur Krebsvorsorge bin ich natürlich schräg und wäßig.
Haben Sie irgendein Problem?
Nee, bisher läuft es alles ganz normal.
Meine Periode ist auch regelmäßig alles gut.
Vielen Dank.
Frau Franke, ich habe eine Frage.
Geht es Ihnen besser, nachdem Sie erbrechen haben?
Ja, subjektiv denkt man immer, jetzt ist es raus,
aber in Wirklichkeit waren die Schmerzen nicht weg.
Und die Übelkeit war auch nicht weg, als ich mich übergeben habe.
Okay, meine zweite Frage ist, wann war Ihre letzte Periode?
Oh, das ist drei Wochen her.
Drei Wochen.
Und könnte es sein, dass Sie zurzeit schwanger sind?
Würde ich eigentlich ausschließen.
Oh, ich weiß es nicht, danke schön.
Frau Dröger, Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie so weit sind.
Habt Ihr Ihre Haustierungen gefragt?
Nein, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Frau Franke, gibt es etwas,
dass die Schmerz in der Versteckdoline der Krebsvorsorge
und den Schmerzen in der Versteckdoline im Ausbau von einer Körperhaltung zubereitet?
Ja, ich habe versucht mich im Bett so hinzulegen,
dass ich keine Schmerzen habe, aber irgendwie hat es nicht funktioniert.
Also, ich würde sagen, da hat nichts die Schmerzen verbessert.
Okay, danke.
Frau Frank, könnten Sie sagen, woran die Libasirose Ihres Brudars liegt?
Der hat schon ein bisschen viel Alkohol getrunken.
Ach so, ja.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Sie Fieber oder pülen Sie sich fieberig?
Er hat sie gefragt.
Ich fühle mich nicht fieberig.
Aber gemessen habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Kannst du mir anfangen, René?
Guten Tag Frau Oberarztin.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Es geht um Petra Frank.
Sie ist 42 Jahre alt, 1,72 m groß und 80 kg schwer.
Frau Frank, ich stelle mich heute bei uns wegen, seit gestern Nacht.
Ich habe heute eine sehr gute, dünne, postprandiale, optimale Schmerz im Epigast Room 4.
Die Schmerz-Intensität ist hier mit 8 Phon-Sien bewertet.
Die Schmerz ist hier, in den Rücken aus Stralen.
Sie klagt über auf nausea, einmalige emesis, momentan zotbrennen auf meteorismus,
warme Flasche, Lindart, warme Flasche, warme Flasche, hat ihnen nicht geholfen.
Die Frage nach Fiba, Nachtschweiß, Stülphurals wurden verneint.
Die vegetative Analyse bis auf in Appetanz und beschwärte Bedingt in Somni, unaufwählig.
Sie leute auf Migräne, deswegen auf Beiber, gegen Migräne auf Medikamente ein.
Sie haben keine Allergien, sie haben Unfallterechtigkeit.
Sie rauhe seit 20 Jahren ein Pakum, der es bestätigt, Nikotin Aboussus, 20 Pakums.
Sie trinken zwei Flaschebieraben und Markmal Schnaps im Fest.
Sie haben die Lebo-Frosse aufgehängt und Alkoholkonsum aufhängt.
Frau Franke ist Laborantin in einer Fabrik und verharatet habe sie wargesunde Kinder.
Sie habe nicht so viel Stress bei der Arbeit, nicht übermäßig.
Die Analyse war unaufwählig, sie sind vollständig geimpft.
Sie treiben nicht regelmäßig Sport, sondern manfallfahrrad fahren.
Sie haben die Analyse aufgrund der Analyse, die sie verharatet haben.
Dann werde ich dann mal auf die Alpira, ob es Abwäschung oder Resistenz gibt.
Dann werde ich natürlich auf die Haut beachten, ob es Verharbung der Haut gibt.
Dann werde ich natürlich Bulut abnehmen, in Späson, Bulutbeet, Asylumsparameter
und auf die Sonore füllen.
und auf die Haut beachten, ob es Verharbung der Haut gibt.
Wenn Sie Ihre Diagnose bestätigt, was machen Sie damit der Patientin?
Ich habe die Patientin-Stationen aufgenommen.
Natürlich werde ich eine solche Patientin, die Physiotherapie einleiten.
Natürlich, wenn ich auf die Abwäschung, wenn ich eine Medikamente, eine Schmerzmittel,
eine Analyse, eine Neuargensuars, eine Neuargenspropyra,
dann ist diese Medikamente nicht ausreichend, weil ich die andere Opelde wie z.B.
Pilitre mit einleiten.
Und natürlich, ich werde auf Elektrolyt-Werte überprüfen,
weil es könnte auch Hip-Hop-Kasemian sein.
Deswegen könnte es als Süngabe auf wichtig sein.
Sehr gut, ja.
Die Patientin, zum Beispiel, leidet sehr.
Deswegen könnte sie mitkommen.
Stimmt, ja, kann man auch noch machen.
Gut, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, wie es der Frau Franke geht
und nachher gucken wir uns die Patientin dann auf der Station zusammen an.
Okay?
Ja, gut.
Ich fahre die Sie informieren.
Ja, das ist gut.
So, wir sind fertig.
Ich kann gleich ein bisschen etwas zur Manöverkritik sagen.
Was mir auffällt, Sie haben gesagt,
die Prüfer haben Sie nicht gut verstanden.
Und es ist ein ganz auffälliges Muster bei Ihnen.
Sie verändern die Vokale.
Aus dem E machen Sie ein A.
Aus dem A machen Sie ein O.
Und das führt dazu, dass man wirklich ganz schwer Sie verstehen kann.
Und nicht, wie man das jetzt abstellen kann.
Aber Sie müssen wirklich das mal kontrollieren,
sehr bewusst, oder auch sich von jemandem,
der im Alltag mit Ihnen zusammenlebt, sagen lassen.
Also ein E-Trombase.
Man kann das gar nicht nachmachen.
Sie verändern die Vokale.
Und man muss wirklich sehr stark die Ohren spitzen,
um zu hören, was Sie meinen.
Gut, das ist diese Sache.
Dann ist mir aufgefallen, dass Sie natürlich sehr nett immer die Patientin mit Namen angesprochen haben.
Aber das war schon jetzt sehr häusig.
Aber was Sie eben immer verwendet haben, haben Sie.
Ganz selten, meine andere Formulierung ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass.
Das war diese Geschichte bei den Fragen, der Fragenkatalog.
Das haben Sie eigentlich schön konsequent gemacht.
Und da würde ich jetzt nicht viel daran kritisieren.
Dann kommen wir zum Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Da sind natürlich die sprachlichen Schwierigkeiten immer ein bisschen größer.
Das wissen wir alle, dass das viel schwieriger ist, frei zu formulieren,
als wenn wir nur einen Fragenkatalog praktisch abarbeiten.
Da ist aber mir eine Sache aufgefallen,
das ist wirklich grammatikalisch so schlecht.
Und zwar, wenn Sie sagen, wegen,
dann müssen Sie bitte auch den Genitiv bedurzen.
Sie können nicht sagen, wegen pro-grediente,
zunehmende, pro-grediente,
heftige, plötzlich aufgetretene, drückende Schmerzen,
sondern wegen plötzlich aufgetretener, pro-gredienter,
drückender, schmerzl-genitiv, redigbedurse.
Sie müssen eine andere Formulierung nehmen,
dass Sie das wegen weglassen.
Sie stellte sich vor mit den und den Beschwerden.
Was mir dann aufgefallen ist, die Geschichte,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob Sie es ausdrücklich erwähnt haben.
Ich bin mir wirklich nicht ganz sicher,
habe ich nicht gut aufgepasst, ob Sie das erwähnt haben,
dass die Schmerzen nach fettigem Essen aufgetreten sind.
Müssen die Kollegen mir vielleicht sagen,
oder Sie, Horchen nochmal, ich kann es echt nicht mehr sagen,
ob Sie es erwähnt haben.
Was Sie erstaunlich fand in der vegetativen Anamnese,
haben Sie gesagt, die Patientin hätte Nachtschweiß verneint,
aber da haben Sie sogar noch nachgefragt,
haben Sie gesagt, Sie sind in den Wechseljahren.
Sie hat ausdrücklich angegeben, dass sie Nachtschweiß hat.
Sie hat, Sie haben gesagt, ja, manchmal fährt sie Fahrrad.
Ich habe gesagt, sie fährt jeden Tag Fahrrad,
sie fährt jeden Tag zur Arbeit mit dem Fahrrad.
Das ist nicht mal, aber es ist natürlich nicht aktiver Sport.
Das ist klar.
Dann ist mir eine Sache aufgefallen,
ich glaube, das würde den Prüfern auch ein bisschen unangenehm ausstoßen.
Wenn Sie sagen, bei der Untersuchung,
oder beim Vorgehen zur Untersuchung,
ja, natürlich werde ich Blut abnehmen
und natürlich werde ich eine Abdomen-Sommer-Sophie machen.
Nicht natürlich, ohne natürlich.
Ja, und das haben Sie ungefähr fünf Mal gesagt.
Und Sie haben das auch noch einmal gesagt, bei der Therapie nachher.
Das ist, glaube ich, so etwas nach dem Motto,
fragen Sie mich doch nicht,
ist doch völlig klar, dass man das macht.
Aber ich glaube, so etwas kommt in der Prüfung tatsächlich
nicht besonders gut an.
Insofern vermeiden Sie das.
Okay.
Ja, also ich denke, fachlich überhaupt kein Thema
und sprachlich ist es wirklich etwas,
versuchen Sie an Ihre Aussprache zu arbeiten.
Ja.
Dass Sie wirklich auch Texte mal ganz bewusst lautlesen.
Ja, das, was ich irgendwelche Anamnese-Texte,
die Ihnen vorliegen oder die Sie selber schreiben,
dass Sie einfach nochmal sagen, zusätzlich teilt Sie mit,
dass die Schmerzen bei acht von zehn auf der Skala sein,
und sich auch nicht bessern ließen.
So, sprechen Sie die Worte richtig aus
und hören Sie hin, ob die richtig klingen.
E muss wie E klingen, A muss wie A klingen,
O muss wie O klingen.
Ja, und dann kann man Sie deutlich besser verstehen.
Ich glaube, ich zumindest, ja, machen Sie ein Versuch.
Okay, ja.
Das war es, was ich dazu sagen kann.
Ja, ist irgendwie ein anderes Problem als sonst?